veamos si podemos simplificar 5 por la
raíz cuadrada de 117 y entonces vemos
este 117 y pues no se ve como que sea un
cuadrado perfecto no recuerda que los
cuadrados perfectos son los números que
uno tiene al tomar un número por ejemplo
tres y elevarlo al cuadrado y eso lo que
nos da es 9 entonces 9 si es un cuadrado
perfecto entonces pues este 117 no me
parece que sea un cuadrado perfecto pero
pues vamos a ver su factorización en
números primos a ver si encontramos por
ahí algo que podamos simplificar pues
empecemos por borrar esto de aquí y
haber 117 es divisible entre 2
no es divisible entre 2 porque es un
número impar entonces vamos a ver si es
divisible entre 3 y pues en algún lugar
de caná khadem y vimos que si tenemos un
número y sumamos cada una de sus cifras
que en este caso es 11 + 7 y eso es 9 y
si esta suma de las cifras es un
múltiplo de 3 entonces el número entero
o sea 117 en este caso es un múltiplo de
3 y como uno más uno más 7 que es igual
a 9 es un múltiplo de 3 entonces eso nos
dice que 117 es un múltiplo de 3 o sea
que podemos dividir a 117 entre 3
entonces pues vamos a dividir a 117
entre 3
aunque entonces hagamos esta división el
3 no cabe en el 1 pero el 3 si cabe en
el 11 y cabe tres veces entonces 3 x 3 9
y queremos restarlo entonces 11 menos 9
nos queda 2 y tenemos que bajar el 7
y el 3 cuántas veces cabe en el 27 pues
caben unas nueve veces tres por nueve es
27 restamos y nos queda 0
entonces 117 es igual a 3 por
39 aunque entonces este ya es un factor
primo pero este número todavía lo
podemos descomponer más en primos no
haber es divisible entre 2 no porque es
un número impar pero será divisible
entre 3 definitivamente sí porque 3 más
9 es 12 y 12 si es un múltiplo de 3
entonces esto se divide en 3 por 39
entre 3 es 13
ok entonces ya tenemos la descomposición
en números primos de 117 porque 13 ya es
un primo entonces 117 es 3 por 3 por 13
entonces podemos reescribir este número
como 5 por la raíz cuadrada de vamos a
tomar estos dos números que ya aquí se
empieza a ver como estamos buscando
cuadrados perfectos verdad pero bueno
tenemos aquí 3 por 3 y finalmente este
último factor primo por 13 ahora lo que
vamos a hacer aquí es una de las
propiedades de los exponentes no me
queda claro si ya lo vimos o lo vamos a
ver en algún lugar de esta lista busca
esos vídeos de las propiedades de los
exponentes pero bueno mientras tanto me
vas a tener que creer que cada que
estemos sacándole raíz a dos números que
se están multiplicando
es igual a multiplicar las raíces de los
números aunque entonces tenemos que esto
es igual al 5 por la raíz cuadrada de 3
por 3 por la raíz cuadrada de 13 ok si
tenemos dos números que se están
multiplicando ya eso le sacamos raíz eso
es igual a multiplicar las raíces de los
dos números que se estaban multiplicando
ok lo vamos a ver o ya lo vimos con todo
el detalle del mundo en los vídeos de
las propiedades de los exponentes pero
mientras tanto vas a tener que creerme
bueno el chiste es que ya que escribimos
estas raíces de esta forma pues aquí ya
tenemos un cuadrado perfecto no o sea
tenemos 3 x 3 que es 3 al cuadrado y si
a 3 al cuadrado le sacamos raíz lo que
tenemos es un 3 okey porque recuerda que
la raíz es el número tal que si lo
elevamos al cuadrado nos da ese número
y aquí sí a tres lo elevamos al cuadrado
pues si nos queda tres por tres entonces
todo este pedazo es igual a cinco por
tres que es 15 y ya nada más nos falta
multiplicar por ra es cuadrada de 13 y
listo ya simplificamos 5 por raíz
cuadrada de 117 hasta llegar a un número
que no se puede simplificar más porque
el 13 es un número primo bueno yo
propongo que veamos otro ejemplo
entonces pues tratemos de simplificar 3
por la raíz cuadrada de 26 ok entonces
lo que vamos a hacer es sacar la
descomposición en números primos de 26 y
así buscar cuadrados perfectos que sean
factores de 26 como lo hicimos aquí
sacamos la descomposición en números
primos y buscamos ahí a los cuadrados
perfectos y aquí obtuvimos a 3 por 3
entonces eso es lo que queremos hacer
con este 20
así es que saquemos su descomposición 26
definitivamente es divisible entre 2
porque es un número par entonces lo
podemos escribir como 2 por 26 entre 2
es a 13
13 pero 13 es un número primo entonces
no lo podemos descomponer más así es que
la factorización en primos de 26 es 2 y
13 ja pero entonces aquí no podemos
formar ningún cuadrado perfecto bueno
eso lo que significa es que ya no
podemos simplificar más a esta expresión
de esta expresión ya está lo más simple
que se puede poner entonces esta
expresión la dejaríamos tal cual como
ésta